[Music]
well welcome to the second session of
this ideas and action series of
workshops these are these are workshops
that are focused on practical philosophy
usually uncommon real-life issues I tend
to alternate stoic and Aristotelian
stuff although next time we're going to
do something with epicureanism and
pleasures and desires I wanted to keep
these very small this one's going to be
you know quite small in part like Andy
was saying parking is not very good
tonight so that instead of just doing
lecture and discussion like I do in a
lot of my talks I could do some real
work shopping and this one is focused on
an issue that we've chose in part
because Valentine's Day relationships so
I wanted to broaden it a bit I
originally thought romantic
relationships and Aristotle's types of
friendship because my students are
always bringing that in whenever I teach
Aristotle's three types of friendship
even though Aristotle doesn't really
talk about that quite so much and then I
thought well it could be good to talk
about relationships more more broadly so
we're going to be applying Aristotelian
practical philosophy drawn sort of
directly from the source Aristotle you
don't actually need to know anything
about Aristotle although I think all
three of you actually did know no about
Aristotle in order to get something out
of this session but the way that we
structure these is so that people don't
need to do that so some of this might
seem a bit of review you don't have to
buy in wholesale either to find this
this useful I am myself an Aristotelian
I play a stoic in in some places I like
things about the Stoics but I'm actually
much more Aristotelian in many respects
so I'm Greg Sadler I'm a philosophy
professor I've taught for about 15 years
at various places and I've been giving
lectures and leading workshops for about
10 years I'm also the president of
reason IO where we put philosophy into
practice and that's part of what we're
doing with these these sorts of
presentations and workshops another
thing that I do
philosophical counseling where we use
resources and techniques and ideas from
mostly in my case ancient philosophy to
help people work through life problems
or make decisions so these these monthly
workshops we do these free is a public
service of reason IO and we record them
so that my viewers and subscribers can
can you know participate in a somewhat
limited way through the comments on
YouTube so what we're going to do in
this this section there the session is
more or less corresponding to that big
bubble thing with the notes that I have
given you we're going to start with sort
of a sense of the background or current
situation I always like to get the feel
of the room you know in this case about
relationships and about Aristotle I'm
going to do a little bit of lecture
talking about some some Aristotelian you
know the philosophical tradition some of
the key points about it we'll discuss
some of the problems and questions and
dilemmas that we encounter when we think
about relationships ranging from family
relationships to romantic relationships
to things that we encounter in groups or
John we're gonna do some some Q&A here
and there I've got two Broke broking and
breaking it up here and there with that
and we'll also do some work shopping
we've got two worksheets that I've
created just so we can use those for you
know points of reference and these are
things that you could you could take
home if you want and fill out at your
leisure or scribble out and dice
whatever you want to do with them the
other things I do want to talk about is
is what enjoying the highest kind of
friendship requires and some of the
pitfalls if people commonly end up in by
mixing up different kinds of friendships
and then I want to bring things to close
in conflict by talking about conflict in
relationships and and where Aristotle
sees that from how Aristotle sees that
coming
of mixing up these different sorts of
relationships
so let's actually start with the
Aristotle part I think all of you can
say that you you've read Aristotle you
understand Aristotle fairly well right
yeah and this is a I think some some
parts of varicella are really hard to
make sense of you know people have to
read the categories when they're
starting out and and they're like what
the hell is this stuff I don't know what
this is the metaphysics is you know
rather difficult admittedly the ethics
is fairly straightforward the sections
on friendships seem really
straightforward so that's good what
about relationships let me let me ask
you this and be as honest as possible
how many would of you would say the year
you're really happy overall at the
current condition and status of all of
your relationships yeah every one of
your relationships across the board
samway coworkers no no okay
how many of you would say you're
extremely dissatisfied anybody no that's
good
did you'd be a miserable person
relationships are very important what
about you know say would you say 75% of
your relationships are on a good footing
you you have an idea about where they're
going or yeah so everybody that's that's
oh that's very good because you know
it's easy to have one relationship going
well and then have another one goes
south sometimes it'll put strain on the
the first relationship you know there's
kind of a cascading effect sometimes
here's a couple other things if you were
put on the spot how many friends however
you wanted to find friends how many
friends would you say that you have
would you say less than ten or less than
50
what do you think what would you say I
think that's how we define friends I
mean there's maybe a handful of people
that I'm very very close to God and then
a much larger circle that I am friendly
with and would consider to be a friendly
acquaintances and maybe even a friend
but not they're not the people that
would help me move for example or that's
kind of yeah who will actually show up
if they promise to move because not
everybody shows up that's an important
function that that Aristotle talks about
what about you guys how many would you
say you've got
with almost on an everyday basis
probably between five and ten in circle
expense like a drink with a good time
and the expense of Facebook friends yeah
that with other that was sort of the
next question I was gonna guess how many
how many friends did on social media
now Facebook counts friends LinkedIn
counts contacts Twitter its its
followers right which sounds a little
bit you know different than friends
Google+ its Google+ followers that's
right yeah
what's Instagram use Instagram item okay
so it's mostly Facebook that's friends
right that uses the language of friends
how many Facebook friends you do you got
a lot yeah but that includes well I mean
includes people I met in universities so
they're not necessarily people I'm still
in touch with that people I know yeah
we're taught you know how many of you
guys okay well you guys have less than I
did I thought I had relatively few I've
got about 400 or so yeah but a lot of
them are people that I got back in touch
with because I went to high school with
them or elementary school or whatever
yeah so you know it's a good thing to
think about are these really friends in
any sort of sensor or not and that's
something we'll I think maybe close with
at the end so I I can I'm going to go
over the very basic points about
Aristotle and the Aristotelian tradition
not because you guys don't know this
already but just for for my viewers
Aristotle you know we know as the
student of Plato eventually forms his
own distinctive approach and
philosophical school and it becomes one
of the great schools of ancient
philosophy the Lyceum or the Peripatetic
school and there's a strong emphasis on
both empirical observation and doing
dialectical philosophy meaning taking in
what other people have to say and then
seeing whether there's anything to it or
not you know critic
sifting it trying to form it together
into a overall comprehensive account and
overall I think you can say the aerosol
is a systematic philosopher he's you
know there's there's parts that may not
fit together that well but for the most
part it's a coherent system he's looking
at just about everything he possibly can
because he was he was an omnivore
intellectually so everything from
physics and and biology you know what we
called nowadays the Natural Sciences to
politics to you know rhetoric and and
poetics metaphysics you know he grapples
with as many things as he possibly can
it must have been really something to to
be in his school you never know I
suppose what you were going to encounter
his discussions of friendship and the
range of relationships that are involved
there are situated primarily in terms of
ethics there is some discussion of it
and other works like the rhetoric or in
the topics or in the politics but it's
primarily in the two ethics that we're
looking at and again I don't need to
tell you guys this but I want to say a
little bit about ethics or moral
philosophy many people think of it as
and just involving either following or
deriving rules that it will tell you
what to do you know when we have a code
of professional ethics that's usually
just a set of rules about what you can't
do or what is incumbent upon you a lot
of people also think about it in a more
or less utilitarian fashion it's about
outcomes and producing the best outcomes
overall in that that makes you a fickle
for Aristotle is from many ancient
philosophers that there's much broader
concerns involved and friendship fits in
with that so you know there's character
is really central flourishing or the
good life whatever we we count that as
lifestyle what we nowadays call
lifestyle Aristotle just talks in terms
of lives but it's really what we call
lifestyle with with its own set of
priorities and then relationships and
today Aristotle you know has some
influence
you you know there's an academic mole
you know more or less yeah still
scholarly approach in terms of virtue
ethics so there's societies that are
devoted that there's a vast literature
that many of those people do focus on
practice I know you know for example
some some risky Chileans who work in
business ethics and do some excellent
work and in there somebody even write
about things like circuses right
but there's also a you know it's not
quite so big or our evident as the sort
of neo epicurean movement or the neo
stoic movement where people come right
out and say we're worse you know neo
Stoics or neo Epicureans there are a lot
of neo Aristotelian x' in with a sort of
lower case a out there there's a lot of
people talking about character education
about the virtues sometimes what they
say get their saddle wrong or waters it
down a little bit too much but you can
see that there's a lot of interest in in
this sort of thing so I think it's a
very useful approach what we're going to
focus on here comes mostly just from the
to ethics the Nicomachean ethics and the
you Demian ethics both of which you have
to tell us interesting things about the
nature of friendship or better set
philia because philia doesn't just mean
friendship in the sense that we think of
it encompasses a whole range of
relationships so let's think about
common problems or issues arising from a
relationship let's take Valentine's Day
since that just passed it's a very
concrete starting point what sort of
issues arise from that holiday for
people you know you never have bad
Valentine's Days but you know but I'm
sure you've had some in the past you
know what wrong
we had a spotter anything I'm just
joking around because you know well
actually no I mean the Valentine's Day
was the day that my grandfather died
action Oh No yeah I mean it's a
bittersweet day for me anyway because he
was very important to me so yeah yeah
but of course I don't have bad melon
plantain seeds no Valentines yeah I know
I know I'm just joking around with you
because you know yeah but it would I
mean I could think of all sorts of
things that typically go wrong somebody
doesn't do what they're supposed to do
and now the relationship gets called
into question and you don't really care
about me how do you know if somebody
cares about you you have to figure out
the right kind of gift or maybe there's
not a gift involved and a card should be
involved or flowers of some sort you
know the prices for everything gets
jacked up on Valentine's Day because
they know that you know people are gonna
be buying things at the last minute what
are other issues that come up with
Valentine's Day that's if you've got a
relationship I was thinking yeah there's
pressure yeah
yeah if your interest is also this
expectation you have to also protocol
you have to go up a nice restaurant
offensive wasting what you got to get
the right gift a specific holiday yeah
it's the Valentine's Day is just sort of
a day when the fault lines and
relationships become evident okay you
could think about it
what about broader issues what are
issues you see up coming up sort of
relationships in general what are what
are things that you have always thought
were weird or paradoxical or puzzling
well you mentioned social media and oh
probably all of us could relate to the
idea that there is a series of
expectations that go with social media
like there's a poll yeah and a set of
rules and unwritten assumptions about
you know allegiances and loyalties and
you know not liking something every
night I overheard someone having coffee
when I was working on the Hudson job
today and you know someone was very
upset because they had posted something
someone
haven't liked it and that became a
barometer for their you know yeah age
menteur support of that decision and
that's just you know that's a whole
different set of the applications and
expectations that I don't think oh and
we certainly didn't have that being
friends with someone when you could go
to their house and bring their doorbell
and you come out to place at one point
ya know like everything is very well I
you know I'll admit that one of the
things I did for Facebook and I do this
with other social media and as I turned
my birthday thing off so nobody can know
when my birthday is because then I don't
have to respond to happy birthday stuff
and it gets me off the hook of having to
wish anybody a happy birthday some
people think that that's not a good
thing but I I see it as a good thing and
you know that's it's one of those great
examples of where I might be alienating
some people by not wishing them happy
birthday
sometimes I'll piggyback on other
people's birthday wishes though right
so but there's all sorts of issues like
that you know I wrote down a whole bunch
of things that I've found puzzling in
the past and I know other people do and
I think these are all things that
Aristotle can respond to who really is a
friend who isn't this is a classic
problem because people use the word
friend pretty loosely and sometimes in
manipulative ways right the friend Zoe
Cho anything and you know like for you
you mentioned moving somebody really is
a friend and you call them up do they
need to help you move they have a bad
back maybe that gets them out of that or
if they have to pack stuff then you know
are there limits some people want to say
that there aren't any real limits so
once a person really is a friend you'll
do anything for a friend that's what
loyalty demands
can good people be friends with bad
people this is this is an interesting
one I think a lot of us have experience
with this sort of thing another way of
thinking about that is our bad people
sometimes good friends at least you know
we see people that we know are actually
bad in one sense or another and it seems
like they do have friends so is it
possible for them to be good friends how
good of a person does one have to be in
order to be a good friend
how do those those connect with each
other another one that comes up is it
right is it okay to get romantically
involved with somebody at work or in
other places where there's there's
connections already existing where this
is already a relationship in place that
you know a lot of relationships are
formed a lot of romantic relationships
are formed where there's a matrix of
other relationship some of the other
things I put down was you know the the
friendzone phenomena or the frenemy
phenomenon era some of course doesn't
talk about that but I think that he
could talk about it in interesting ways
so a few general points about
Aristotle's theory of friendship or
relationships so I think that one of the
things that we we have to keep in mind
is that we have to do a little bit of
translation work when we're dealing with
Aristotle just in you know part cuz he's
writing in a different culture a long
time ago there's some assumptions that
are rooted in culture that we might no
longer agree with so framing marriage
for example primarily in terms of the
useful he it's interesting because we
often we often make mistakes in romantic
relationships by thinking a romantic
relationship automatically has to bear
the brunt of being everything that
Aristotle calls full friendship
Aristotle didn't think that he thought
that romantic or erotic relationships
were mainly about pleasure and you know
the sort of lasting lifelong
relationship between husband and wife
was more about utility or benefits or
you
fulness filling in the gaps unless about
you know sexual desire or romance or
anything like that we might not agree
with that you know he also has a very
heavy stress on living together in the
same physical space and I don't think
that we necessarily need to think of our
close friends as living right on top of
us you know especially since we have you
know social not just social media but
but we have the capacity through Skype
and things like that that get to connect
with people let's start with with
relationships so when things are going
well it seems like there aren't any real
practical problems posed as a matter of
fact people don't want to think about
problems with relationships when things
are going well precisely because you
know make makes them feel good when
things aren't going well then we tend to
be posed with all sorts of practical
problems and the biggest problem is
being resourceless not having some you
know distinctions or concepts by which
we can figure things out because our
culture doesn't do a great job in
guiding us with that so if we had a
better or fuller understanding of
relationships if we understood what's
going on and what has gone on or what's
possible or probable and what decisions
would be good to make then I think a lot
of things become a lot easier and
Aristotle can help us with that so
Aristotle begins his discussions by as I
said he's a dialectical thinker so he
begins by noting with what other people
say about the topic and people who were
as confused about relationships back
then as they are today as a matter of
fact maybe even more so even though
things were a bit simpler back then so
he notes some puzzles or problems that
are arising in his own time one of the
classic ones was is it is it primarily
about similarity or is it about
difference is it opposites attract or or
you know birds of a feather as we say
right which is the basis for for
friendship another problem is can one
can one be friends with many people in
any real sense seems like there's an ex
Civet ii to friendship the closer it
gets the more time you spend with the
other you're saying you know maybe five
people you can spend a lot of time with
if you're doing that you can't spend
that much time with the other people so
are you depriving them of your
friendship in some way common complaint
made by people in other relationships
like your family members right you're
spending too much time with your friends
how do other kinds of relationships you
know familiar familial relationships or
romantic relationships or business
relationships fit into the matrix of
friendship this is a question for the
ancient Greeks and I think it's a
question for today and then another key
one is how should friends treat each
other what do you owe to your friend and
what did your friend Oh to you so some
of the key ideas that we're gonna
explore an outline here and these are
all interconnected with each other
are this classic distinction that I
think everything else turns around
between three kinds of friendship for
Aristotle and they're based on goods so
instead of basing it simply on say the
structure of the relationship he's
basing on something else the idea of
friendship as a complete type of
friendship that's another important
thing unequal friendships that's
something when people teach this
material or read this material they
often go to the three kinds and then
they skip the stuff towards the end
about the unequal relationships but
that's the most interesting stuff
because most relationships don't have
perfect parity involved romantic and
marriage relationships I want to talk
about some of the particular
characteristics of those and then
towards the end we'll talk about some of
some implications what the fullest type
of friendship requires of participants
what we should expect from the other two
kinds of friendship which which are
legitimate and have a very important
place in human life and then how
conflicts and disagreements arise so
let's start with the the three kinds of
friendship now I give you a handout
about that it's quite lengthy you know
very detailed we go through the whole
thing I just wanna hit on some of the
key now it's here so
there's three basic kinds of goods
they're not the only types of goods but
this is a very comprehensive distinction
that Aristotle makes and many other
thinkers have made between the useful
good you know is it in Latin the bonum
eta is how it gets called the
pleasurable good and then the good as
such and this is a little bit harder to
frame Aristotle himself uses different
language to talk about that sometimes he
just talks about it as thought good
sometimes he talks about it as the the
fine or the noble good the the count
long sometimes he talks about in terms
of virtue and when we whenever talking
about friendships we're actually talking
about these as being basis for the kind
of friendship that we've got going on
so there are friendships that are based
on the useful good and that means that
the people involved in them are
providing useful goods for each other so
you invite somebody out for a cup of
coffee
you know you enjoy coffee it's something
that is pleasurable hopefully maybe
maybe it isn't maybe you're just there
to you know talk to them because their
business contact and in which case it's
just totally about utility and that
pleasure at all but they're giving you
something and you go along and you know
maybe you listen to their nonsense for
half an hour you know you're giving them
something in return to write but it's
not something intensely pleasurable
that's not really the source of it
you're you're each giving something in
return and getting something out of it
that's a basis right at the other
extreme we have the people being
involved in a very close friendship
where they know each other the they
admire each other they like who each
other are it's not just about what
they're getting from each other it's
about who they're getting who they're
who they're also giving to each other so
everything else in between is is some
sort of relationship and so these three
goods provide us with a way to
distinguish very important
dividing lines between relationships he
also makes another important set of
distinctions that I just want to point
out we could talk more about these two
if you want to he talks about the
difference between what really is good
and what appears to be good this is
something we get mixed up about a lot
and the reason why we get mixed up about
it a lot is because we're nunna well
maybe some of you are but I'm certainly
not perfectly virtuous as a matter of
fact I wouldn't even say I'm half way
verges I would say at best I'm on the
way to virtue some I've got you know a
little bit better down justice pretty
good
temperance not quite so much you know
you know generosity pretty good with
that you know good temper not so much
you know these things if we don't have
all the virtues we're not going to be
entirely clear about that what really is
the good and what's just the apparent
good we're gonna make mistakes with that
from time to time it's part of why we
need other people to sometimes you know
say to say to us hey here you're screw
it up then there's also the pleasant to
a person and the pleasant as such this
is a little bit I think harder to wrap
your head around at first
what's pleasant to me might not actually
be pleasant Aristotle says what he means
by that is it's not what is pleasant to
the person who really is in a good state
so for example if you know so I've got a
coffee here and I like drinking coffee
and I think a lot other people like
drinking coffee too but I could have an
acquired taste that's screwed up because
I've been doing it so long let's say I
like pouring a little bit of kerosene in
there every so often right I don't know
what that tastes like but I had
relatives who you know back in the days
to gargle with kerosene - you know
remedy for the cold terrible idea but
you know I'm sure it tasted awful but if
I had begin to like that Aristotle would
say your taste is screwed up you managed
to corrupt it somehow right when you're
sick and
some things taste good to that that
aren't really tasty
he also examples of he's got an example
of wine that you know tastes sweet but
isn't really sweet it only tastes sweet
at first and then if you keep on
drinking it it loses its flavor it
reminded me very much of the the blind
taste test between Coke and Pepsi I
don't know if you guys know about this
so Pepsi wins if it's just like a
thimbleful because Pepsi is very sweet
if you have to drink an entire can Pepsi
loses to coke or @rc because people
don't like that sweetness you know time
after time after time it's sort of along
the lines what eres littles talking
about but now it was not just in terms
of taste but think about the entire
range of what we enjoy right
there's also he says what really is
useful and what what is useful to a
person so a good example of this would
be somebody who is an alcoholic
you know it's useful to them to do what
they need to do to get a drink but it's
not really useful as such you know it's
it's useful in the particular
circumstances that they're in but it's
not the useful as such so these are good
distinctions to make and insofar as
we're not entirely good just like with
the apparent good and the real good we
can get mixed up about these things and
we often do now let's let's talk about
the idea of friendship and its full
sense and I give you another handout
about that and this one I actually do
want to refer to because there's all
these different interesting points that
Aristotle stresses so this gives us the
sort of outline of what a genuine
friendship would would have to include
so to begin with this is sort of you
know the absolute fog of mere kind of
baseline friendship is personal if I say
that I'm friends with Siri on my iPhone
Aristotle would say you're nuts that's
you're not Friends of Siri Siri is not a
person you know what about pets or
things like that I would say insofar as
we treat them as having personality
maybe they you know we can have friendly
relations with them
so probably the higher animals it makes
more sense to talk about that it
probably doesn't make sense to talk
about being friends with your pet
tarantula
because soso difference probably gonna
get some some comment from you somebody
on YouTube who's very attached to their
tarantula now you the other thing now we
start getting into the personal
friendship involves wishing good for the
other if you don't have that in some
sense even if it's just wishing good for
them so they can do something good for
you
there isn't a friendship there in its
fuller sense friendship involves mutual
wishing good for the other there's a
there's an interplay back and forth we
we not only wish good for the other for
the others sake they do that in return
to us he also thinks it's important that
friends realize that they are friends
that that may sound a little weird how
could you be how could you be friends
with somebody but not actually know that
you're your friends can you can you
think of cases where this this could
happen well he says people could wish
well to each other but not actually
realize it they might even think that
they're enemies but wouldn't wish well
to each other these sort of things
happen every once in a while
friendship is based on having something
in common now that something in common
could be a set of needs as it often is
in friendships are they useful or it
could be you know as substantive as
totally articulate view of the good life
that you're trying to realize together
it could be anything in between
it could be vlogging you know chat about
blogging you start to become friends
with somebody it could be you know maybe
somebody has a passion for x I know a
guy who actually cares about ties quite
a bit because he puts it on his Facebook
you know water to set of ties the name I
I don't get that myself you know
but he's really really into it and I'm
sure he's got friends who are super into
it as well
friendship involves a shared life in
time this is a really interesting one so
does it make sense to talk about having
long-lost friends from Aristotle's
perspective maybe those people aren't
really friends in the full sense you
know if you haven't been engaging with
them if you haven't been interacting
with them he thinks that you have to
spend time with each other no again I
think that we could do this virtually I
think that in our own time it's a lot
easier to do this you know well great
mind if I use our beginning of our
relationship we had an epistolary
relationship you know we met in high
school you know work together in the 90s
without realizing who each other were
and then connected on Facebook started
writing back and forth to each other
until Facebook blocked us because we
were writing too many words created Andy
created a blog we wrote back and forth
with that and used Google Chat and had
decided to get married before we'd
actually spoke it on the phone because
we were able to do with a pistol Larry
relationship now from Aristotle's
perspective strictly speaking that that
probably was you know that irrational
yeah you're right yeah but it's you know
it's an example of how one can in fact
do a lot of these things without being
in the same place at the same time for
all of these features and so it's not so
much that you know I mean we worked this
thing it helped that we had a common
basis to being from the same place
but I mean the features were present
before we made it mean yeah now feature
seven deliberate choice this term pro
raices is one that aristotle uses it's
one also that Stoics use in a somewhat
different way but it's very important
because the pro raices is really at the
core of the person it can mean the
individual choice that a person makes
choosing one thing or over another I
like choosing coffee over over water but
it also refers to how you orient
yourself in general so virtues and vices
you know good and bad habits are matters
of your pro races you form your prior
races through what you do and your pro
races also feeds into what you do so
there's a there's a sort of feedback
relationship there and he says that
friendship has to have some some
component of this at least in its full
sense he'll actually talk about you know
sharing the same perceptions sharing the
same you know choices that's that's
essential to friendship this is part of
what breaks friendships up to when
people make a bad choice stick through
it their friend says look I can't go
along with you on that I'm trying to
bend as much as possible but at a
certain point I have to let you go
friendship itself is a prior asus as
well or as a matter of crisis the last
one is really interesting friendship
involves not only sharing joys but
sorrows Aristotle will talk about
sharing and pains or sorrows friends you
know are the people who are there for
you not just to do things but also to
listen to your nonsense after a breakup
you know and tell you that that there's
other fish in the ocean and that you
know he or she is a jerk and and you
know you could do better all sorts of
things right
that's Aristotle I think it could get
behind that friends also also should be
rejoicing this is where say a friend is
different than a frenemy right the
frenemy is somebody who puts on the
front of being a friend but secretly is
dying
a little bit inside every time that you
succeed every time that you enhance you
know they're they're trying to bring you
down that would be that would be a you
know a fundamental difference there so a
couple other important points it's
possible even actual much of the time
for people to want to be friends with
each other without actually being
friends with that person this is this
you know we see this happen a lot of the
time especially because time is a
commodity that we never have enough of
so there's lots of people who you say
I'd really like to get to know that
person and there's there aren't enough
hours in the day either you don't have
enough hours or they don't have enough
friendships by the way that it based on
usefulness or pleasure are not going to
consistently have all these
characteristics this is just the the
fullest type of friendship and in
Aristotle's view this is something I
suppose we could have a little bit of
discussion about only genuinely good
people who you know have developed the
virtues can enjoy full friendship that
might be that might be a good point to
have a little bit of discussion you know
myself I think that you know we don't
necessarily have to be fully virtuous in
order to have that that sort of
relationship but the less virtuous we
are the more pitfalls there's going to
be you know maybe it's enough that if we
do evaluate things rightly and we're
oriented the right way and we realize
that we were not you know entirely where
we need to be and we're not like
concealing that from ourselves and
pretending to be better than we are
maybe we can't enjoy full friendship do
the one thing I would say about that is
it is it is a bit painful to try to be
try to act virtuously if you're not
virtuous the the as aristotle says the
self controlled person they know what
the right thing to do is and they do it
they make themselves do it but they
don't really like doing it and that's
one of the big difference it's the
virtuous person
lots to be temperate like if I you know
so I don't I'm not a temperate person
that's part of why I'm at the weight
that I am you know I can diet
I can't exercise I can you know do
portion control
I don't enjoy doing that I do do it
because I want to lose weight you know I
don't do it because I actually take joy
smaller portions if I was virtuous if I
did have the virtue of temperance I
would enjoy them you know I would see
that as a I would not only see it as a
good thing I would feel it to be the
good thing that it is so what I mean
what do you guys think about this is it
possible you've seen these eight
characteristics is it possible for those
of us that aren't virtuous aren't yet
virtuous to have that that sort of
relationship with another person or is
you know the lack of virtue gonna
preclude us from that
this is where you can tell the
aristotelian from the neo resilience you
know what do you think
I guess my reaction is if we're looking
stupid these 8 features yeah do you need
to be virtuous money my instinct is to
say no I'm trying to give an example but
maybe my understand your virtues of it
all I'm thinking of like you watch I'm
like this 3 channel rainy like histories
are like these husband wife children oh
and they're like evil evil yeah yeah but
like they fit every single feature but
we wouldn't describe my virtuous at all
and yet there's somehow that reciprocate
versus oppressor prosody that we're
talking about here yeah that's an
interesting example let's see it
involves wishing well okay so they they
know they're friends they do have
something in common they're sharing life
does involve deliberate choice let's say
they do share joys and sorrows are
actually sympathetic with each other and
the I guess like the key would be the
wishing good for the other hand if I
need a diversion link yeah if you think
if you if you wish good for another
person you're not gonna want them to be
a serial killer
I mean this is where that's where they
like the apparent good and the real good
would come in I mean I think they would
say well I think being a serial killer
is a wonderful admirable thing so of
course I wish that yeah I want my my my
husband or wife to be the best serial
killer possible realize their potential
that sort of thing yeah
I wasn't thinking of anything quick to
extremes I thought yeah that's a good
it's a good example yeah well let's move
on and talk a little bit about unequal
friendships and I'm not going to say
awful lot about this unless unless
you're more interest than that but so
there can be friendships in which
different partners are unequal because
they offer different things to the other
people as we say they put different
things on the table or because the other
person desires different things and a
prime example of this is a person who's
pleasant to have around makes a good
dinner guest or a person to invite to
parties or somebody to take along as a
plus-one not necessarily as you know
romantically involved that kind of
person will have friends who enjoy their
company the friends themselves may not
be that enjoyable they may be providing
all these benefits because they want the
enjoyable personal life so one person is
getting usefulness out of it
free meal access contacts all those
sorts of things
the other thing clothes who knows the
other person is getting pleasure out of
it
Aristotle talks about other cases where
a person may in fact enjoy the virtue of
another person but then they don't know
they don't invert you to contribute
themselves so they they contribute
something else like they buy them dinner
they invite them over they they're
pleasant to be with they're witty you
know these sorts of things also included
our relationships where there's a kind
of imbalance in the structure so he
talks for example about rulers and
subjects in a political sense I think
you could think about bosses and
employees in this sense or you guys you
know your your graduate director or
dissertation director and yourself
you're not in the same power position
that's very clear right it's if there is
a friendship it's going to be an unequal
friendship in that respect he does make
make sure to specify that the
relationship couldn't be of say master
to slave insofar as the slave is a slave
and nothing else there's no friendship
possibly says so if you're treating your
employees
as you know in a despotic manner you
know assumption as a slave master it
would be impossible for friendship in
any any sense to exist even the
friendship of the useful there's a
different kind of relationship going on
there pure power relationship he talks
about parent and child parents and
children are not on the same basis for
Aristotle the idea of being your kid's
best friend
I don't think Eris thought it would get
behind them he also you know this is I
think one of the places we probably
would want to say Aristotle you probably
have based husband and wife he sees that
as a necessarily unbalanced relationship
where it's supposed to be aristocratic
and then he complains about it usually
being done in an oligarchy cool way
where it's just about power and wealth
and he talks about Eris's who sometimes
run the show and he thinks that's a bad
idea I think probably we have to we have
to differ with them on that but there
are these unequal friendships and when
we're looking at romantic or marriage
relationships sometimes they could be
unequal relationships like this
sometimes they could be equal
relationships
he tends to see matters of eros or
sexual desire or attraction infatuation
law however we want to frame it as
primarily being about pleasure all right
and he says that they're very excessive
he all he complains at many places not
only the ethics but in other works about
young people tend to you know only think
in terms of eros because they're they're
not entirely formed
they haven't matured now we know you
know from from you know studies of the
brain that the human brain is not
completely developed until well into the
20s so there probably is something to
what Aristotle is saying about that
there there are a lot of people who are
more mature you know I think blanket
condemnation of young people is probably
a bad idea
but he does he does think that that
younger people tend to be more
influenced by euros than older people as
a matter of fact he has terrible things
to say about old people like you know
seniors he's
there-there unpleasant nobody wants to
be around them but that's the Aristotle
now he he he also tends to view the
husband wife relationship or any sort of
marriage relationship like I've pointed
out so we could think about we could
extend this to two you know notions of
people cohabitating or domestic
partnerships anything where there's this
this you know being in the same place
and sharing a household he sees those in
terms of usefulness to each other within
the framework of the household they
bring different gifts or skills right
and he tended to break this down along
gender lines I think it may be more more
fluid now in terms of functions he does
however hold out the possibility of
virtue being involved if the partners
have that to offer if they don't have
that to offer you know that's not a
possibility and he thinks that if there
is virtue that can even be a basis of
attraction so it doesn't necessarily
have to just be about being useful to
each other or you know sexuality and and
and you know erotic desire and romance
and all that there can also be this
higher level where the people love each
other or are friends with each other for
their own sake because of what the other
person has to bring not just in terms of
what they can provide in terms of
usefulness or pleasure but in terms of
who they are who they are at their core
he thinks that that's gonna be pretty
rare though now Aristotle didn't seem to
think that that would be what you would
look for in a spouse in the Middle Ages
of course that's going to change there's
a very interesting conversation that can
be had about that in our time that's one
of the prime problems that we run into
because so many people whether it's a
spouse or even just a boyfriend or
girlfriend place that that massive
stress that the you know being all of
all these things to the other person you
know all these features of friendship
that somehow come out of the fact that
you're dating somebody or sleeping with
them or you know living in the same
place or things like that and you know
if you think about the logic behind that
it's it's pretty pretty strange the
notion that you just sort of naturally
spontaneously occur it if it doesn't
then there's something wrong with you or
something wrong with them or or the
world
Aristotle say what makes perfect sense
you know if you want to enjoy the finest
type of friendship the most
comprehensive one that's going to take a
lot of work and you're gonna have to
develop virtue so let's take a little
pause here there any questions or
comments or things that that are sort of
spurred or sparked that you want to talk
about but I said three questions oh wow
very organized okay so maybe there would
be short I don't know oh so this is
aerosol I were talking about what like
the stove it's an epicurean called
carrier itself not as such he does think
that I mean he talks in the stuff about
friendship about can he be friends with
yourself he's also got discussions that
you know in the portions on Justice
being can you get be unjust to yourself
or not and insofar as you are parts
right you're not insofar as you have
different parts to your being or
different dimensions however you want to
translate the you know parts of the soul
you're like a community it's very much
like Plato's idea or the three parts of
the soul they can be in line with each
other get out of whack and and one
should really be in charge the other one
shouldn't force it Aristotle does think
about things that way and
I mean if you wanted to read into his
stuff something like what is being later
on discussed as a care of the self I
think you could read it in he's just not
talking about it explicitly you know and
he does think too that I think the
Epicureans of the stoic they really
stressed this as well you can't be fully
who you are isolated from everybody else
your your relationships without
everybody else are gonna play into that
you know you need to have friendships
ideally they should also include family
members but you know it could just be
you could be an orphan and have enough
friends and live the good life
so that's yeah I think that's
it works to say that there's something
like that the nearest ATO yeah so I
think the second question you kind of
already answered okay goes in line with
features two three and five I think one
of the ways I've encountered people
talking about it like 21st century
languages like my friends and I we share
with values oh I don't know yeah that
way
no yeah he just he talks in terms of
goods yeah but insofar when we think
about what it is to shoot to have values
right that is that fits into what
Aristotle is calling Pro erases because
your prior ASIS he uses it in three
different ways this is sort of leading
off into a a different discussion I have
a paper and working on I've presented
before that's specifically not this so
the bottom level of pry races just means
individual choice I chose to get this
coffee I chose to get it with with
chocolate and caramel in it instead of
just getting a plain old latte because I
wanted something sweet right that's an
individual choice and I chose this
instead of something else and like say
no coffee right I gave up something some
money in order to do that then there's
like prior ASIS in terms of sort of
overall structures of the the psyche the
soul virtues and vices are not just
habits that are generated but they're
they're structures of pro races so you
could think of that as sort of you might
say prioritizations right and so when we
talk about value that's fitting into
that Aristotle also I would like to
argue uses prior ASIS in a few places in
a even more broad sense similar to how
the Stoics use it where it is the core
of the person when he says that prior
ASIS is
or excess DNA I think a which means
desire or a facticity that is informed
by my mind or intellect and is also at
the same time news or XDK which is you
know sort of the flip side of that which
is intellect informed by by desire or
mind he's talking about the core of the
person their entire you know personality
and that involves values right now it's
interesting because the term prior ASIS
if we look at phenomenology of values
like my Schaller or or Dietrich von
Tilden breath and we talked about
preference that's a translation of for
name and in the German choosing one
thing over another and for name and
lexically is the same thing as prior
ASIS yeah yeah pro you know in place of
or ahead of high racist it's literate
hydrating is is naming they're the same
actual and so it's it's what you set
higher and what you set lower so when
we're talking about what we value if I
let's make it very concrete is it
important for me to go to my kid's
birthday or should I do work instead you
know doing work would be beneficial to
me and could be beneficial to my kid if
I think about things in the broad scheme
and you know kids will have lots of
birthdays right I can't give up all sort
of justifications but it is also
important to mark that occasion and to
show that I care about that person which
which gets the prioritization that that
you know how I make those choices shows
what I actually value right and so with
friendship this comes in or
relationships in general this comes in
all the time how do you know who really
is a friend they show up to help you
move if they say they're gonna help you
move but they don't show up to help you
move because they had to you know play
video games instead you know exactly
where you rate you know you know exactly
what they value
if they if they even if they screw it up
you know did they say they're sorry and
try to make it up to you or don't they
that shows you what they value right
there's all sorts of things and these
are usually this is the last thing I'll
say about this but these are usually
over determined so they could be ready
these kind of decisions when they're
added multiple ways you know because
there's a lot going on there because
that's a part that's part of what makes
human being some interesting you know is
this messiness what was here it was your
other question um you mentioned how for
Aristotle that's the time he'll use
arrows and all Tigers uh-huh well one of
my classes close her makes of the
subject okay
lectures across and he uses what arrow
us in a relationship to carry the self
yeah ask dr. bender why does he just not
use Philo's yeah and he said well
Foucault something to the effect of
Foucault is thinking of arrows obviously
not like in a romantic sense but in the
the intense desire yeah and so for I
must explain for Foucault philosophy is
a cut is a kind of erotic Enterprise
because your desired knowledge mm-hmm
and when Foucault is talking about the
Epicureans and the Stoics he'll perhaps
talk about arrows in the context of a
relationship not again as sexuality but
as this intense desire to know the other
so I don't I guess I'm kind of I don't
even know if I'm asking a question but
is it fair to do that it should be that
terror sort of it is in everything
because I'm not fluent yeah
it's but is it fair to distribute
Aristotle this kind of intense desire to
know my friend or is that just bracketed
out of this consideration
no that's he just doesn't talk about it
but you listen Lee but it's it's
implicit because how would you know how
would you know the friend who you love
and their virtues such as like you just
sit back and let it wash over you there
there's there's you know friendship is
an activity it's an energy for him
the the other thing I would say about
that too is the Greeks very often
there's a whole range of desire law of
attraction friendship words that the law
can play off of so for example in the
symposium the symposium is supposed to
be about eros but all the other long
terms get thrown in there as well and
they play different roles the Republic
has this long discussion about different
kinds of philia which we translate in
there as being more like it eros like
you know philipose a person who loves
horses is wild about horses so I think
they have something in common with
horses they they just want horses and
they do talk about horses bet on horses
ride horses breed them you know somebody
who's I suppose Phil oh I know is a
hardcore drinker or it kind of swords
they often would say so yeah there's you
know Aristotle is using heroes in this
case just to talk about the kind of
relationships where somebody's you know
if somebody wants to screw something
else somebody wants to get getting
involved sexually with somebody else but
you can you can use your us to talk
about broader desire in general like
Plato did in the symposium saying that
you know we all are driven by your
by the time that we get to the 20th
century we've got somebody like Freud
you know I'm talking about libido
another yet another synonym thrown in
there libido can be libido is supposed
to like originate in sexuality in some
way but sexuality isn't just about sex
you know there's very mysterious
connections there and so then it's like
can be everything so why not just call
it desire you know Alexis in general and
sometimes they do you know and then we
get the whole bunch of Freudians all
doing different things with Freud and
it's very complicated very quick any
other questions or comments
sure
yeah those are really good questions and
the answer he has he has nothing to say
explicitly about either but I think he
could have said things about it somebody
who does talk about the first issue who
really liked Aristotle's take on
friendship with Cicero Cicero in his on
French have talked quite a bit about
when when you should end the friendship
and how you should end a friendship now
of course Cicero is a politician
as well as a philosopher working at a
time
when friendships were tearing apart the
body politic and his view was you can
really only have a sustainable
friendship with somebody who is virtuous
at least in a general sense you can't
you know sooner or later you're gonna
run into strains and you're gonna have
to break things off with other people
who just aren't aren't up to that
because gonna ask you to do things that
you know are wrong so and we could think
of a lot of examples of this where we're
friends with somebody and they do things
that we find repugnant but we feel a
sense of loyalty to them so we don't we
don't tell on them to begin with and
then they want to bring us into it we're
like yeah I can't I can't do that with
you and you know things become
acrimonious and then we have to say look
I just I can't I can't go along with
this anymore it's harder to do now
because then you have to defriend them
on Facebook yeah walk him on the phone
there's other things that come with and
it wasn't like in a pastor you can just
just not go to the where they hang out I
don't take their calls you know when we
had caller ID what was the other thing
you know the feelings if somebody breaks
up with you
Aristotle has nothing to say about that
explicitly but I suppose what he could
say would be something like well you
know you would you would want to think
to yourself about why did it why did it
break up is it a good thing or is it a
bad
have you been deprived of something good
if you are if they if they broke up with
you because they said look I can't stand
the stuff that you do maybe that's a
sign that you're vicious you need to
change right there's little you know one
of the things that's puzzling about him
is he seems to talk as if the vicious
person can't realize their own
viciousness but they must be able to
otherwise they couldn't ever break out
of that cycle and I think that when we
think about our own experience it's
usually somebody saying to something
you're a real screw-up you know what the
hell's wrong with you that we sometimes
have these you know moments and that if
we if we have the right you know support
and we actually choose to make the right
decision sometimes it takes a lot of
times we can steer ourselves away and
just become you know uncontrolled and
then self-controlled and then maybe even
virtuous but it's tough because there's
that Marvel that moral blindness there
and any of think about what happens when
a lot of people get somebody rejecting
them or breaking up with them they want
it to be the other person's problem all
right they you know they're they're a
jerk or or you know they don't they
can't see what what's you know what's
good for them but really it's it's
probably about what's wrong with them
all right so I'm actually gonna just to
save it a little bit of time I'm gonna
skip over the two worksheets that we've
got but you welcome to fill them out one
has to do with like sort of making sense
of your current web of relationships
that's worksheet one and I think it
could be good to force yourself to have
to write down who fits in where because
our tendency in the society that we live
in almost we're very realistic with
ourselves is to want to put everybody in
the great category yeah but they don't
all fit in there some people quite
frankly we're just friends with because
they're fun we enjoy them and there's
nothing wrong with that
those things many people the bulk of the
people that were friends with we are
friends with on the basis of usefulness
again Aristotle thinks there's nothing
wrong with that he thinks there is
something wrong with pretending that
were friends with them on the basis of
them being really really great people
who say that we're also really great
people and we admire so much about
ourselves
we're living in a kind of self-deception
if we do that and setting ourselves up
for all sorts of problems probably we
should have fewer people in the being
friends in terms of virtue category than
in the other categories and because you
feel guilty in breaking it off then
Aristotle would say sometimes people say
well I think maybe down the line they'll
change or will recover this you know
just knowing them for like chronological
history shouldn't be enough to keep them
with you I mean Facebook is kind of a
haven for that sort of stuff people feel
guilty about D friending people on
Facebook but I think Aristotle would say
be ruthless and pruning here Facebook
yeah well we'll talk a little bit more
about that when we get to how
friendships dissolve in terms of the
other two types but there were a few
other things I wanted to like point out
with that that worksheet one of the
things is what are you doing it think to
yourself how would these people or other
other people that you know how would
they place you in a worksheet like that
where would you fit in for them
and then you know you should ask what
you owe the people on that worksheet you
should oh the people in one category the
people who are useful much less than the
people who are in the you know this
might say the inner circle you don't
know everybody the same thing Aristotle
would say but we get this pushed on us
by our culture that we have you know if
we're friends with somebody we're gonna
go to the limit for them and if we don't
we're bad people Aristotle would say
that's that's really misguided let's go
on and talk a little bit more about the
highest friendship so Aristotle thinks
that you know in order to admire virtue
in something there's got to be virtue
there all right so for a an equal
friendship you know the witches which is
at the highest level both people would
have to be virtuous it's definitely not
going to be something that's possible
for people who are actively bad that's
not going to be possible I don't even
think that it would be possible for
people who are what Aristotle calls mccr
attic or they lack self-control the kind
of people who are always making the same
mistake they know it's a mistake and
they keep on making it because first of
all it's hard to admire somebody like
that you know you can you can love them
despite them being a screw-up but they
are a scrub and you know they're not
going to get an awful lot done in terms
of great things and you can't rely on
them so even if you have you know virtue
developed or something like that
probably it won't be that it won't be
possible if you're self controlled like
I said before and the other person's
self controlled and you do recognize
what the good is and you want to be
better people I think that's a sort of
it's possible and we do admire people
who want better things even if they're
not attaining them so long as they keep
making progress towards it if they just
want it and never make any progress it's
a little bit different right then we
don't quite believe them but it's not
going to be as enjoyable in that case if
you're always having to struggle against
it
Aristotle thinks that the highest form
of friendship shouldn't just be you know
loving or being friends with the person
for their own sake because of what's in
them it should also be pleasurable and
it should also be useful to you friends
who really do you know love each other
care about each other are going to do
good things for each other they are
going to invite that they are going to
buy the round of drinks they are going
to help you move right that's that's an
issue of usefulness but there's gonna be
that higher level as well and if they're
not pleasant you've got to ask what's
going on there if you know that if
you're hanging out with somebody and you
want to be associated with them because
you think they're a great person but you
don't enjoy being with them Aristotle
would say there's something going
something wrong there something
something is mixed up he also notes that
relationships like this tend not to give
rise to conflicts between the people why
not because they want to do the right
thing in relation to each other the
other worksheet that I had created for
you has to do with like what it would
take to have that kind of relationship
who would be your ideal person what sort
of traits would they they have to have
and I think it's useful to to think
about that again it's if you do this
sort of exercise what I've found if
you're you if you're honest with
yourself you discover things that you
don't normally think about and you put
them down on paper and now you have
realizations that you really are looking
for this you really do want this things
that you might have thought were
absolutely essential if they're not on
the paper maybe they're they're not that
important it is also important to think
about why these appeal to you where we
are talking before about what's really
Pleasant and what just you know is
pleasant for this particular person
doing that exercise will help reveal
that you you put it down on paper and
you look at it you're like maybe maybe I
like the wrong kind of things sometimes
so
let's talk about the other kinds of
friendship now so remember how we talked
about that that a rib that question that
was you know the Greeks were really into
it we still talk about today is that
opposites attract
or birds of a feather so eros is what's
both it's it's birds of a feather for
the pleasant Pleasant people are you
know Pleasant usually in the same thing
with each other people who like to drink
a lot together and joke around that's
something they have in common right and
he says that when it comes to opposites
friendships of usefulness tend to be
about opposites but not total opposites
where they would totally destroy each
other you know like Superman of bizarro
her matter an antimatter he says that
they're opposites that tend towards a
means in between them and that mean is
the the reciprocity of what they're
giving back and forth to each other now
I want to stress I can't stress this
highly enough Aristotle says there is
nothing wrong with these kinds of
friendship they're not they're not you
know worse because they're not the best
kind of friendship as a matter of fact
he thinks that we need to have lots and
lots of friends of utility and we should
have friends that are just friends with
us because we enjoy their company but we
don't think that they're great people
and we don't want to get to know them in
the the depths of their soul or anything
like that they serve some very important
purposes bless you in our lives where we
often go wrong I think in our culture
and Aristotle thought people were going
wrong in his own culture is assuming
that these kinds of friendship needed to
be treated exactly as we do the full
kind of friendship so when we do that
were causing problems for ourselves and
here's here's some of the ways that it
happens for a lot of people these other
two kinds of friendship this is as good
as it's going to get if you've got
somebody who's you know really fun to be
around but they're not a great person
and they're not interested in making
moral progress that's okay
that
their choice that's who they are they
don't have to be paragon of virtue in
order for you to enjoy them if you
expect them to become that so that you
can have this highest form of friendship
with them you're probably going to be
disappointed and you're you're not going
to be pleasant for them you're gonna be
an annoying best for them friendships in
terms of virtue are hard to come by and
they take time to develop they can
develop out of out of the lower kinds of
friendship but it's it's you know it's
very hard to predict what if that's
going to happen or not sometimes people
get trapped by their own failure to
distinguish between these so you know
they think that they have to treat
everybody with the same sort of absolute
loyalty as they would the best friend
other people manipulate you know people
who have that viewpoint on that basis it
makes you very easy to steer into things
if you know that somebody is prone to
this excessive blind almost loyalty it
makes it very easy to get them to do
things that aren't good for them these
kinds of friendship Aristotle says they
last as long as their basis lasts so the
pleasant you know if the people aren't
getting pleasure out of what was
originally a pleasurable relationship
that relationship ends Aristotle says
that's natural that makes sense so we
think about you know the hookup culture
for example for example the hookup
culture is essentially about player
right it might be about utility of
somebody's you know wanting to get gifts
or things like that or advancement or
opportunities but it's primarily about
pleasure and if people are getting into
these these relationships and the
relationships aren't very long-lasting
because they don't enjoy each other's
company genuinely but just enjoy having
sex with each other once in a while
Aristotle doesn't think that's a good
thing in particular it's probably not
great for society but it's
you know it's better than trying to take
that and make that into a marriage or
you know some sort of lasting
cohabitating friendship where the people
have to pretend like they really enjoy
each other's company all the time or or
think that you know the projects that
they care about the most really matter
to each other
eres good perhaps we're gonna yeah you
know to make social pins that them
outside of work would be something
because it's not you know it's extending
it in some other way I mean we've it all
sounds a little like mill utility and
higher and higher and lower pleasures
yeah I'd have to think about that that
mill seems to like well yeah mill
certainly places conversation as a
higher pleasure than say having sex
having sex is basically at the same
level as eating for him which yeah not
very high oh yeah I don't think mill
knew a lot of chefs they might have put
it a little bit eating a little bit
higher but yeah I mean that the notion
of like these are my office friends and
and this context you know it works they
may not even be pleasurable in another
context no they're they're about
pleasure you're not getting something
out of them that's useful for something
else you're just getting pleasure out of
them but it but it's it's a limited
thing yeah yeah and you know to think
that just because they're they're
pleasant to you that you're actually
going to get something useful out of
them would be a mistake as well you know
but people do this sort of thing and
it's a little bit counterproductive to
insist that relationships last longer
than their basis does he also says these
kinds of friendship they're not about
the person as such so they don't need to
be about the purse
such so you don't have to pretend like
the person who is doing something useful
for you is your best friend forever that
you you know you want to gaze into their
soul and you know connect up with for
you know forever that'd be a little bit
weird for Aristotle and if they want to
do that with you that's a little weird
too right that's probably a red flag he
also talks well the stuff that he's
talking about would fit in with some of
the the problems that they come up with
other relationships where people talk
about being best friends forever when
they're in grade school or in college
you know that's probably the worst time
to pick you know when you're in your 40s
maybe when you we've got half your life
lived and half for your life still left
to go maybe if you don't get hit by the
bus that would be when you actually
would be able to decide somebody's gonna
be best friends forever because you've
weathered enough stuff but you know we
see people making these sorts of
decisions and then making themselves
miserable by trying to stick to them
when the relationship doesn't really
admit that romantic relationships many
romantic relationships are not really
meant to be the people are not they're
compatible in the sense that they can
enjoy each other's company they can
watch a show they can you know perform
sexual activities and in ways that are
pleasurable for each other because it
tends to be pleasurable in general maybe
they like the same music or something
like that for a while but that's not
enough to make a lasting deep intimate
friendship that that that sort of stuff
can't sustain that weight so Aristotle
would would say I think that it makes
sense for younger people not to make
promises about forever maybe some people
don't actually need to think about
relationships forever except in terms of
the one friend that they want to have
for good or five friends or
or things like that or they you know
they decide I want my marriage to be one
of those those places or my you know my
partnership or whatever there's also a
lot of other expectations that people
have about family that we haven't talked
about one of them you know people think
that families should always be close
unfortunate and that I'm in a big enough
family where not everybody has to be
close to each other because because you
couldn't you couldn't be and so you
don't have to actually like everybody
you know not everybody likes everybody
we're okay with that because you can
always find somebody that you like and
who likes you you know but but a lot of
people feel as if you're related to
somebody you have to find some way to to
really like them in the depths of their
being and Aristotle would say no some
people are unpleasant and some people
are really drags on you you know maybe
it's okay not to you have a very close
connection after a while maybe it's okay
for people to grow apart and if they
want to come back together there has to
be a basis for that another thing I
thought about with respect to this
organizations try to inculcate this
we're all a big happy family we're all
friends we're all on the same team and
business organizations are fundamentally
about utility they're about usefulness
you you occupy the slot that you're in
so long as you are more profitable to
employ than to fire and to expect that
people should have this effective
relationship with their co-workers with
their boss with the company as a whole I
think is very very exploitative and in
you know from an Aristotelian
perspective law to try to do we should
also think about our social media
friends and connections and this perhaps
it's okay to defriend people you know
LinkedIn is a great example people even
feel guilty about severing contacts on
LinkedIn LinkedIn is explicitly about
business contacts and people being able
to do things for other people so if
you've got somebody on LinkedIn and they
haven't logged in for a year
so okay that cut them loose you know but
people still feel bad about this because
there's that friendship or we might say
so let's let's talk last about conflicts
and other properties bless you
so why the conflicts arise in in
relationships do you talk about values
that's that's a good example that's
that's one of the places where you get a
lot of if you have incompatible values
and you're stuck in the same place in a
relationship with somebody those are
gonna come to light sooner or later you
know election years are good for that
like right now conflicts most often
arise in friendships of usefulness
aristotle says and unequal friendships
one exception to this is erotic
relationships he says and he's talking
about cases where one person is doing
the pursuing and the other person is the
pursuit they behave like people in a
utility relationship where both are
trying to get a little bit more out of
the relationship than the other one and
accuse the other one of not putting in
enough in the case of lovers it's very
often well you don't do enough for me
you don't show me you love me you should
you know do this or do that or do that
they're their lover over there does that
but you don't do that for it for me is
how it comes up usefulness it makes
sense each person tends to think they're
getting less than they want to or could
be getting from the other band people
can be useful to each other or to non
bad people but when you mix a bad person
into a relationship it's it's asking for
trouble Aristotle says because either
they they just cause conflicts right off
the bat or they themselves are in
conflict with themselves they have
trouble remaining consistent and
constant and what they do desire so if
you get involved as somebody who's a
real mess you're you're gonna have a
hard time remaining friends with them
there's gonna be conflict arising and
Aristotle would say it's it's you know
you could say well I'll just accommodate
myself to them and some people would see
that it's a good thing Aristotle would
say that's a bad thing that's bad for
you but that's going to the care of the
self Aristotle would say you need to
make sure that you're actually being
taken care of in the friend relationship
the frenemy relationship kind of fits
into them - right because what's going
on when somebody is a friend of me
there's always conflict but it's it's
being done in a way that conceals the
conflict right
people say fighting things and then sort
of say they're just joking or they're
envious of your successes they laugh at
your failures doesn't say they're
commiserating with you sometimes set you
up for failure friend of you can a
frenemies that are actually in the
relationship together where each one is
the front of the other one and it's
almost like a rivalry and you wonder why
they're actually friends at all well
there's let's say they're not friends
they are enemies there just concealing
it from each other there's that there's
a conflict right right there there's all
sorts of other reasons why conflicts
arise but I I tend to think that a lot
of it comes from putting too much stress
on relationships that just aren't made
to bear that kind of stress if we think
that everybody who I'm friends with has
to be my soul mate or everybody that I
date has to be my soul mate that's a
problem because they can't all be that
merry I know - I'm waiting for that
person and I did a video of soul mates a
long time ago remember yeah but you know
there's lots of reasons why conflict
what it would arise
I think Aristotle gives us a good sense
about how we can see them coming up
ahead if we understand our relationships
how how we could he doesn't tell us
about how to get over
conflict maybe find another friend who
can we can commiserate with you know
what strikes me that the only friendship
then actually expires really in some
sense is the friendship of utility
because of friendship bones desire well
yeah people people get bored with each
other sure but yeah you know I think
about this ageing people get involved in
romantic relationships and they're young
and they're both attracted to each other
they age could be the guy could be could
be the woman who is no longer attracted
to the partner I think part of the
attraction part of the the pleasure is
having the other person attracted to you
Aristotle does talk about that and so
when when that is is gone now the basis
for the the relationship is effectively
ended unless they've managed to move
beyond that to caring about each other
for their own sake because there is
something genuinely admirable in there I
mean the aerosol is very different than
say Christian thinkers who would say
your spouse could be a dirtbag love your
spouse anyway find something lovable and
them love them despite their dirtbag
goodness
Aristotle said well if your spouse is a
bad person you're not going to love them
for that that's you know you have to be
realistic about this so if you can't
move that way or at least move to
finding it more useful to be the
relationship and sustain it
Aristotle interestingly talks about
children as being a way to keep a
marriage together I think one of the
things to those I was thinking about was
the whole issue of
and how that can become sort of the
basis like people who are in front of me
is think of that as actual good in a way
like yeah they turn that into a good
right where it's I mean it's not quite
pleasure at someone else's misfortune
but it's yeah well there can be if
they're directing it outwards that's
something they have in common as being
jerks to other people yeah there is this
great skit I mentioned one time in MADtv
which was his comedy show
that's this couple played by Michael
McDonald and Nicole Sullivan I think it
was and they you see them at sports
matches sitting in the bleachers and
they're just saying terrible things
about everybody's kids that they're slow
they're stupid they're you know all
these different things right and then
the parents will eventually turn to them
and say where's your kid we don't have
kids we just come here to mock these
people and that's all that's that's
that's apparently they have in common
with each other does that sort of like
what you're talking about
I think yeah or commodifying resentment
into something that you like the people
who the people who whisper things are
oftentimes prone to having isms about
those things right like I don't mean to
be acts and then they whisper whatever
it is they're about to say because
they're not able to say that and claim
that that's part of their belief system
yeah and in that same tone is the person
who says I'm not judgmental but yeah
right and let's rip this person apart
yeah right like I'm not judging but boy
they haven't sure whatever it I go into
this whole thing and they're like I know
you shouldn't have to grow up with that
and they're too vicious people telling
one another how how virtuous they
actually are for tolerating the souther
person's failures when in fact there are
two vicious people who given any change
of dynamic
it would be just as prone to be vicious
toward the person there sitting across
from ya and so they've modified it in
some ways so that it becomes a utility
for them it's not just a pleasure it's
their way of certainly how they manage
okay yeah I would be usefulness yeah you
know that would be similar to cases
where you get to people who are each
damaged in a similar way like you know
to alcoholics they'll help each other
cope and for a while they'll go to
meetings and you know they can relate to
addiction with anything that you said
about sex and pleasure or eros the
desire to have somebody that you sort of
like you know yeah
loaded with on whatever level and it
could I mean it could move beyond that
to a deeper relationship but it would
take a lot of work yeah you know there
would have to be you know like we're
talking but with values like turning
towards the good that they don't possess
and recognizing that not in a sort of
like just aspirational way but but we
better get our butts in gear and get on
the road towards the fair we're gonna
die or culinary students talk about that
often they talk about going through this
like okay yeah when you have to go of
course to kinship yeah yeah and you know
and then there's there's issues that
arise with that to where you've gone
through a common experience so you kind
of feel like you you owe them things
that you don't all other people yeah
then they show up you know say drunk at
your doorstep at 4:00 in the morning
looking for a place to crash and maybe
it's not a good idea to let them crash
there or you let them crash one night
and say you got to sober up and and you
know yeah I'm not gonna support this
sort of thing but people feel almost
guilty into having too
yeah and people that you wouldn't be
friends with because there isn't
something you know you might a quite a
friend of Allah bout them yeah you know
in terms of the good or in terms of
pleasure or in terms of usefulness what
what is going on there you know a fear
of looking bad
perhaps it's tough to say but Aristotle
would say that's irrational you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that sort of
thing
you know I think it's very refreshing so
Aristotle would say there's a lot of
people you should cut loose I mean you
know I don't want to say that this this
covers all the possible reasons for a
friendship but I think it is very useful
stuff are you ready to cut somebody off
tonight
deprecated with this apply to meet you
the best type of friendships are there
like your enemies and I pay for that as
they've been pushing my challenge yeah
creative and realize your potential
right yeah yeah but not this I think
it's a great thing about the same time I
think we just did
yeah I don't know so Aristotle would say
that's a matter from Asus right there
isn't any guideline for it but you'd
have to sort of think it out in the case
that Aristotle anij aren't the same guy
Nietzsche you know when he talks about
the however you want to conceptualize it
the the the primal valuation of the
strong who imposed things on the weak
there's the strong and the weak right
and and there's a conflict between them
but the weak are not up to it so then
they bring in results a month and they
find a way to actually chain the strong
life but the strong exist on a level
with each other which is not completely
that inequality but pretty close because
they're always ready they recognize in
each other something that they see as
virtuous which is the ability to impose
something on others to be masterful
right and they'll try to master each
other but but they'll be happy what
they're doing it so it's more like you
know friends who screw around wrestling
with each other except they'll do it
with blades you know or they're their
armies or things like that or you know
maybe today with derivatives and and
takeovers and things like that I don't
lose a lot to be said about that but
with Nietzsche that that whole strata of
the the free the the strong and the
brave they're able to have he thinks
genuine friendships with each other all
these people down here in the mass the
herd they they can talk about friendship
they want but they can't really have
serious friendships with each other you
know not even in sharing result amok
with each other because they're not fit
to be to be friends
Aristotle could get behind some of them
I think for most people to including
myself words to put into practice
because it I think I think there's a
misconception that this is a cold and
calculated and to ever me like wait I
mean a lot of ourselves seriously read
that way right it is I can't miss the
important emotional piece you know by
breaking things aren't even having
different types of intellectual when
it's just to be angry when there's
something wrong with you if you don't
get angry like yeah it feels very rules
bound for a lot of people who probably
could benefit from it yeah you know the
idea that perhaps the utility of certain
marriages that actually began in a place
of desire were to produce children that
would then do whatever and then it's
good enough to like let it go you know
whether it's friendships or
relationships I think familial times are
different sometimes because you're for
so much of your relationship especially
as a child you're not really given the
capacity to fill out the chart right now
I think this is where everything comes
and you're being and you're being taught
by the people who you're with what that
chart ought to look like
yeah and so that creates it's different
yeah yeah you know it's it's a great
exercise I think workplaces could
benefit from this because it's not just
friendship like you said it's any
relationship burning yes
yeah and if you're to look at sort of
like your you know the people even in
your cohorts at school I think it would
be most useful for the people in the
workplace who keep ending up on the bad
end of the stick
yeah because they think that everybody
is not just their work friend but is
their friend friend you know or is the
people who continuously find themselves
you know pass over for promotions but
everybody kind of goes to them for help
bring those citizens because you're
creating a bond is only it doesn't have
that bi-directional arrow right the
usefulness or the that's not a real
that's not a real friendship then yeah
helping people to identify one when
they're not actually friends yeah that
could be very useful yeah
well any other questions or comments
well I thank you for for your time then
and I really enjoyed this it's nice to
have some people who know the text you
know and you can go through it so next
one we're going to do like I said is
going to be about using Epicurus and
talking about pleasures and desires and
the reason I wanted to pick that one
oh and self-control was because next
next month is st. Patty's Day the day of
excess right so I thought talking about
what real Epicureanism looks like could
be kind of useful yeah people associated
with excess now all right
[Music]